よろしくお願いします
それでは今日のテーマについてお話しさせていただきます
人生の改良計画というか
自己改革計画というか
そういうテーマでございますけど
まあ今更という感じもある方々がいるかもしれませんが
大体まあできれば若い人々のことを頭に入れて
これから人生という方々のことを頭に入れて作ったテーマですが
どうなるかはわかりません
で まずお釈迦様の言葉の釈尊の言葉の
まとめて考えると一つ見えるお釈迦様のポリシーが一つあります
で それは一貫しているんですよ
ずっと それはまあまあ俗っぽく言えば頑張りなさいということなんですね
お釈迦様は涅槃に入る時もアッパマーデーナ サンパーデータ怠ることなく努力しなさいという言葉で
最後 アッパマーデーナ サンパーデータ
まあ覚えた方がよろしいと思います
アッパマーデーナっていうのは怠ることなくサンパーデータっていうのはまあいろいろ頑張ってくださいと
まあまあなんかサンパーデータ用意しなさい
準備しなさいというような意味もありますけど
いわゆる努力しなさいと
怠ることなく努力しなさいという言葉を語られて亡くなりました
お釈迦様の遺言はそれなんです
ということは 一貫して仏教は努力しなさいよという一言葉でお釈迦様のポリシーをまとめて言えるんですよ
釈尊も悟り開いたのは
ただ空から落ちてきたわけじゃないんです
生まれた時 家に付いてあったわけでもないんです
並ならぬ努力の結果として
あらゆる観察の結果として得た体験なんですね
悟りというのは それはどれほど大切なことかというと
人類に未だに役に立っている
これからも役に立つ 使用するならば
聞くならば ブッダの言葉はもう誰がどう踏ん張っても間違っているとは言えないものなんです
間違っているとおっしゃっている方々いますけど
まあ調べてみるとそちらが間違っているんであって
お釈迦様は間違っていることになりません
それは盲信ではないんですよ
どういうふうに 論理的にどんな理屈で考えても
釈尊が説くものはその通りで事実真理なんです
だから時代とは関係ない
場所とも関係ない 時々いろんな教えがありますね
ある場所で通用するんですけど
ある場所ではもう関係ないという
我々の世の中でいろんなそういう考え方
いろいろありますね いろいろしきたりやら
また習慣やら決まりやら快速やら法律やらいろいろございますが
それはどこでもいつでもということはないんですね
しかし 釈尊に説かれている真理っていうのは
その時空関係とは関係ないんですね
それぐらいものすごい厳密に
すごい真理を語ったんですが
まあそれがお釈迦様の悟りの結果なんですね
それはただでついてきたわけでもないし
生まれてくると持って生まれたということでもないし
で 努力の結果として得たものなんですね
それが仏教は大事なポイントとして自慢するところなんです
例えばもう一つの宗教と比べてみると
そちらは特別な人間で
生まれる時ももう神であってとか
あるいはもう神がわざとある人を選んで啓示を与えたとかね
それであなた方とは違うんだよと
この人は 例えば最後の預言者と言っているムハンマドですか
もうそれから預言者が現れてこないんだぞと
あなた方とは違いますよと
ムハンマドにムハンマドと言っただけでも大変な身の安全はないぐらい
すごい長い形容詞を使ってます
そういう方々 仏教から見て
仏教を見て何言うか ブッダってただの人間ではないかと
我々はそれが自慢に言うんですよ
普通の人間に生まれて
あなた方よりはもうものすごい人間を乗り越えたんではないかと
究極的な真理を発見したんではないかと
それが人間がやりましたよと
誰の手も借りないで 神から知恵をカニングしないで
例えばコーランというのはそれはカニングですからね
神がこういうことを言った
言ったと言っていることだから
誰かに隠れているんですよ
そういうことでは何もなく
私はこういうことを言いますよと
もし間違っているならば
どんな神でも出てきて間違っていると言ってみなさいよと
それぐらいすごくこのもう強烈に語るんですよ
自信満々で語るんですね
で ある時は釈尊が悟り開いた時から
それから涅槃に入るまで
語る何言葉を語っても
どんな言葉を語っても
それはすべてがその通りであると
ちょっと違いますよと
ちょっと改良しましょうということは誰一人にできませんと
それはすべてサッチャンワーチャー
真実の言葉であると それぐらい自信で語れるんですよ
だからそれが仏教側がそれが自慢にするんですよ
普通にどこでも生まれる普通の人間として生まれて
普通に勉強して ごく普通な人と当たり前で結婚までして
ごく普通の若者と同じく遊んだりとかね
まあ贅沢な生き方でしたからね
贅沢な人々と遊ぶことしかしない
しないし そういう生活していて
やっぱりそれを全部捨てて努力して
生きる問題を解決してみますよと
努力の結果として悟り開いて
もうすべての生命を乗り越えた人間になったんですね
だからそれはなぜ我々仏教徒がそんなに自慢げに言ってますかというと
これ 私たちには明るいメッセージが入ってるんですよ
私たちも捨てたもんではありませんと
どんな人間でも 捨てた者ではありませんと
だから努力してみなさいよと
究極的な最終的に頑張ってみれば
最終的に人間が至るべき境地であるすべての生命を乗り越える境地である
もうお釈迦様悟り涅槃解脱まで体験できるぞと
だからそれ だからこそ我々は自慢して言うんですね
ブッダは人間でしたと
それが我々にとってはすごい明るいメッセージなんです
神の子でしたというよりは
まああの これはある特定の宗教に対して言ってるわけではなくて
この同じ仏教の中でブッダを絞め殺してるんですよ
ブッダが現れたわけじゃないんだと
本当にこの大宇宙の永遠に真理たるブッダがいるんですと
それがたまたま化身して人間にブッダの形に現れるんだよと
そう言っちゃうと 私たちは歴史的に知っている釈迦牟尼仏陀が本当に人間ではなくて
神の再現になっちゃうんですね
ある永遠不滅のブッダの一つの化身になっちゃうんですよ
そうなっちゃうと ブッダがすごいことを言ったっても
そんな面白くないんですよ
そんなのは当たり前だから
釈尊がなんかすっごい何かすごいことをしてしまっても
まあそんなのはまあ当たり前だと
だって永遠不滅のブッダの化身だから
だからそれ自体がブッダを否定することになる
我々には努力しなさいという
私も捨てたものではありませんという
自分が評価することはできなくなっちゃうんですよ
それで私たちは まあ釈尊にできたっても
私たちにできるわけじゃないんだよと
という気持ちになるんですよ
だからブッダが神であるということはね
ブッダがずっと必死で
亡くなる寸前まで説いていた
説かれていたあのポリシーに反対しているんですよ
遺言としても残した言葉を潰しているんですよ
だから 初期仏教の人々はブッダが人間であったよと
もうもうすごい徹して徹底して言う
それがまずいと 他の宗教の場合は神様がいるのに全然そう思わない
それが強烈にはっきりとしておく
なぜならば ブッダが至った境地が世の中で未だに誰にも至ることできなかったんだから
ブッダの弟子たち以外は
それもまたはっきりしています
神話物語いろいろ作って
人々にはいろんなオーラがつけてますが
客観的に見てみるとそんな大したもんじゃないんですよ
歴史に残っている偉大なる人物の生き方を見てみてもね
言っている言葉を聞いてみても
まあ立派なことの生き方
立派なことを言ったりはしたことは確かですが
しかし釈尊の言葉で比べてみると
まあそんなに驚くほど
あるいは人間には想像できんことっていうのは言ってないんです
で 人間には全く考えられないことをお釈迦様はおっしゃってますけど
それまた見事に不思議な言い方なんですよ
ものすごくわかる わかるような気がするんですね
釈尊おっしゃってることは
全然宗教と何とも関係なくわかるような気がします
例えば私が聖書を読んでいるときは
この聖書を書いた人々が我々に与えようとしている気持ち
その感動 もう何でもいいんだから
それが絶対的に神というものは信仰していないと成り立たないんだと
だから最初からもう頭に何かを概念を入れて読むとしかわからないんではないかと
例えば 神って本当にいるのか？という疑問で読んでみちゃうと
全然わからなくなっちゃいますよ
何だこれ？と 変ではないかと
だから どなたでも仏教の人々も聖書を読んで決して悪くはないんだけど
読んで理解したければ
やっぱり一時的でも絶対的な神がすべて支配しているんだぞという前提を入れてから読まないとわからなくなります
そうやって最初から何か前提として固定概念入れてから喋るということは
そんなに立派な手段ではないんですよ
でも 世の中でみんなやってること
これから世界一有名な人が来るんだぞと
ノーベル賞を取った人が来るんだぞと
この人はこういうこういうのすごい人ですよと
まず固定概念つけてから
それからその人言うことを聞く
客観的に見ると もう別にどうということは言ってないんですが
普通世の中はそういう世の中なんですね
それで釈尊の言葉っていうのは
その何の固定概念もなく
もしかすると疑問に思いつつも
読んでみても あ なるほどという気持ちにはなるんです
あ なるほど その気持ちになれない人は一人ももしかするといないと思います
しかし それもちょっと甘いんですよ
このなるほどでわかったと思っても
本当はそうわかるわけでもないんです
人間の知恵の次元というのは
こんなぐなに破ってすごい超越したレベルで喋ってるんです
なのに で なんかわかるような気がしますから
お釈迦様はそれで励んでるんですよ
君も頑張りなさいよと
それがまず覚えておいてください
仏教のこの一貫してやる釈尊のポリシーというか
まあポリシーですね 頑張りなさいという一言葉で
それで我々は何を目指してますかね
努力する人が 今自分が置かれている立場
状態 そこから必ずしも成長して進んでいくんですよ
今のまんまでいいということはまるっきりないんですね
だから仏教は人間にはどこまでも成長すること
どこまででも良くなること
を期待しているんですね
だから かなり激しく 今置かれている状態については
ものすごくもうきつく言うんです
自慢させないんですよ
あなたは素晴らしい人やとかね
立派な方でしょうとかね
そうは言わないんですよ
それが仏教を広げるために出てくる
広げれなくても 仏教を理解する時はちょっとしたネックにもなってます
人間というのは自分をうだてて褒めてくれるとすごく気分がいいんです
そうすると相手言うことは何でも聞く
それで王政の人気というものはものすごい
人気の秘訣はそちらにあるんですよ
大衆の期待に応えなさいと
それが人気の世界 ある女の人はテレビで見たんです
番組ですけど 何か一年四十億かなんかそんなぐらいの収入がある人で
で 年間は漫画家なんですね
まだまだ若いんですけど
名前知りませんし 漫画は見たことはないし
ですから ただテレビで私に必要な情報しか取ってないんです
で なんであなたはそうやって売れた秘密は？と言ったら
あ それは乳首描いたことかもしれませんと
漫画で上半身裸の女の人を描いて
なんか今まで漫画家はそこら辺はなんとかごまかすと
この女の人は堂々とそこは明確に描いたと
それで説明するんですよ
ほとんど漫画読むのは小学生で
もう頭の中でいろいろ妄想があるんだと
特に性的なことに対しては
そこはそのまま満たしてあげればいいと
だから子供の頭の中でもう浮かんでいるあらゆるごちゃごちゃの思考をね
そのまま描いてあげる
それで売れてるんだと
だから大衆が期待するものをあげなくちゃあかんやと
それはまあその通りで
豊かになりたければ 人気者になりたければね
億単位で儲かりたければ
まあその方法なんですけど
それでそれが仏教やりませんね
その中にちょっと理解してほしいことがあるんで
だから今の今の自分を
褒めて正当化して認めると
どうなるかで気分が良くなるだけで
これからも努力しなくてはいけないということは出てこないんですね
自分が自分なりに完璧に頑張ったという過去形になるんですね
それから その人は私のことをよく理解してくれたと思った途端
その人の奴隷になっちゃうんですね
だから おだてた人の意のままの存在になってしまうんですね
だから どんな方向へでも持っていく
導くことか もう追い出すことか
どちらでもできます 徹底的に依存することになっちゃうんですね
だから そこが客観的に見ると
人間にとってよろしいかと
いろんな人に言われるまんまで操る人形のように動かすこと自体が世の中で危険現象ではないんですかね
だから 人のことを本当に思うならば
人のことを本当に心配するならば
その道もそんなに正しくは見えません
しかし 貶したり 怒鳴ったり
間違いばっかり出してくれて非難ばっかりすると
人が落ち込んでうまくいかないということも
それもその通りであるし
それも極端で だからうだてることも極端で
どちらでも良くないんですよ
ただ人を批判して馬鹿にして
落としてしまうことでも何にも役に立ちませんし
おだてたことでも何の役にも立ちませんし
それで自分が儲かりたいという自分のことしか考えない
わがまま 自我 自我 自我で生きている人々が
おだてる道を選ぶんですよ
人を褒めまくる道を選ぶんです
人を非難しちゃうと 非難した人もろくな結果になりませんだからその人はそれほどわがままやっていうことも
ちょっと一概には言いにくいんです
そういうことだから お釈迦様が人間に努力しなさいよと
成長しなさいよと 人間というのは捨てたものではありませんと
なぜならば 私のことを見なさいよと
私はこういうふうにこういうふうに頑張って
こういうふうにこういうふうに努力して
こういうこういう方法で実践して
こんな状態になっているんだよと
それが誰にでもできますよと
というわけで頑張ってくださいということが
お釈迦様がずっと言っていることなんです
だからその指導する立場
教える立場 先生の立場にいるんですね
だから先生という人が褒めたり批判したり
貶したり落としたり また手を出して引いてあげたり
いろんなことをします
一つだけ選ぶということではないんです
どうすればこの人成長するかと
ということを考えているんですね
ですから 一般的には仏教の話を聞くと
今の私の状態は素晴らしいという感じがしないのがほとんどです
なんか頑張らなくては
なんか自分とは違うんじゃないかと
よくわかりますよ これわかりますと思う方々も
自分の心で読んでみてください
心を読んでみてください
自分もそのお釈迦様おっしゃっているところになっているんですかと
その通りやと言いながらも
しかし私はそのところにはなってないんだよと
私はちょっと下にいるのではないかと
一段階 その気持ちは必ず表れてくると思います
では 例一つ挙げます 皆様よく知っているお釈迦様の言葉なんですよ
憎しみは憎しみで消えませんと
それは慈しみを持った人だけ憎しみが消えていくんだと
恨みは恨みで消えませんという有名な言葉でしょ
聞いた それは当たり前でしょ
しかし 自分に当てはめてみてください
それで私だったらどうでしょうか
やっぱり恨みが出たら恨んでやっちゃうんでしょうね
だから自分がもうその通りだ
もうしかりと言ってるんだぞと
よく納得いきますよと思っても
自分がそのレベルになってないと感じるはずなんです
そう感じる人が努力するんです
ちょっと頭が変に考える人は
よくわかりました ブッダの言葉というふうに自慢しようとする
その人々は道を間違うんです
わかっても あなたは何なのかということも大事なんです
あんた大丈夫ですか？と
嘘をつく人は世の中の信頼を失って不幸になるんだよと言われたら
まあそれは当たり前 その通りだと
思っても気分 あなたはどうですか？と
その時はやっぱり自分がその境地になってないとわかるんですよ
それはブッダの言葉にあるずっとあるこの特徴です
それでいつでも読む人がなんか自分を戒められているというか
叱られているような感じがして
それでやっぱり努力しなくちゃという気持ちを出して努力しなくちゃいけないんです
そうすると必ずしも確実に成長します
成長しないで結果がない状態では終わりません
というわけで 仏教は人間の苦しみを完全に消えること
苦しみから完全な脱出を語ってますから
その道を歩めばどんどんどんどん幸福になるはずなんです
不幸なままでは決して終わらないんです
未熟なままでは決して終わらないんです
それが仏教 お釈迦様 また仏教で自慢するところで
仏教っていうのはいつでも証拠で
証拠済みで はっきりと結果が出ますよと
教えが本当かはないかということはもう自分で分かりますよと
死んでからやということはないんだよと
最後の審判まで待たなくてもいいやと
今日 今ここでわかるんだよと
本当かないか そういう風にこの特色
また自慢しています そこまでなぜ喋ったかというと
やっぱりこの自分を直す
自分を改良するというのはブッダの本義であって
そのためにブッダが大変なたくさん教えを語っているんです
どこからどんな経典 どんな一部を読んでみても
我々はより良い人間にしようと
より良いというところにしようと思っているんです
だからお釈迦様はある日
出家のお坊さんたちに言うんですよ
この少々心が綺麗になったんだからといって
少々何か精神的に落ち着いたんだからって満足するなかれ
幸福になりましたとかね
なんか自分が悩んでいた問題は消えましたとかね
あ よかったそれで というふうに思うなかれと
それがもうよくないんですね
とにかく最終的にもうやることをやったと
やるべきことが終わったんだよと思われる瞬間まで
感じられる瞬間まで努力することを応援しているんです
はい そのポイントはそこまで
次に世の中でだいたいは私はダメだというふうに思う人々ももうたまたまいるんです
できっこはないでしょうと
私はもうダメですからと
これがすごい邪見なんですよ
人間思ってはいけないことなんです
私はやっぱりダメですよと思うことは
人間思っては決していけないことなんです
もしどなたかそういう気持ちでいるならば
その人はやっぱり人間を失格する
もう堕落する方向へ 降りる方向へ歩んでいるんですね
それなんで邪見ですか
罪の中で一番重い罪が邪見ですよ
で これがそんなにきつい邪見にはならないかもしれませんだけど
ある時点で考えると邪見なんですね
それどういうことかというと
釈尊があらゆるすべてのものが無常であると変化するんだと
止まっていません 何一つ
[笑い]我々の心も物質も二つしかないんだから
世の中で 心と物質しかないんでしょうに
それはどう見ても見る
見るうちにすべて変わって変わっていくんですよ
だから変わるものならば
どうせ変わるものならば
なんで良いより良い方向へ変えないんですかね
ということなんです どうせ変わるものだから
次にもっといい方向へ変わってもらうと
次にもっと良い方向へ変わってもらうんだと
だから私はダメだなと
私はやっぱり無理だ ダメだと思う人が
その その目に見える事実に逆らっているんです
物事は変化していくんだからね
何一つも固定していないんだから
なんで変わらないんですかね
変わりますよ 否応なしに
それは止まること誰もできません
瞬間瞬間何事も変わっていく
だから絶対的に物事は変わるんだから
ここら辺でちょっと努力っていうものを入れてみて
入れておいて 変わるならばいい方向へ変えると
そういうわけで 私はダメという考え方はそういうわけで邪見なんですね
無常に逆らってそういうふうに思っているんです
真理に反対の考え方なんです
事実に だから邪見ですよ
その場合でも まあちょっと理性を持って考えてほしいんです
例えば体っていうのは変わります
体の変わり方はもう衰え
衰えるというかね 老いるということは
まあ決まってる方向 それは物質だから
まあどうにもならんことで
みんなそこら辺で踏ん張っちゃうんですよ
年取らないようにと いつでも若くていられるようにと
そうやって無知なことをしているんです
年取るスピードをいくらかまあ遅くするとかね
それはまあいくらか可能ですけど
老けてしまうスピードをちょっとまあゆっくりしてもらうとかね
しかしそれがもう変えませんね
その方向へ必ずも変化していく
それに努力するのは まるっきりもう勘違いで
勘違いでありえないことで
このできないことにチャレンジすると
明らかにできないと 事実なので
明らかにできないことは事実なのに
それは見ようとしないでチャレンジする人は
やがてとっても疲れてしまいます
それで私はダメやと だから
ひいて言えば初めからダメですね
考え方もおかしいし それで不幸しか得られないんですよ
それが努力とは思わないんです
当然歳取ることを年取らんようにするということは努力ではありません
どうせ体がもう衰えて
美しさがね どんどん減っていく
それを何とか何とかしようということは努力だと仏教は思ってないんです
無理なことをやってますからね
それあるエピソードでわかりやすく説明しています
このエピソードは別なものを言うために使っているエピソードですけど
私はまた別なことを言うために言いますが
あるインドでお釈迦様の時代のお話ですが
すごい金持ちがいて ものすごいケチで
もう食べない子供一人がいたんですよ
この子供にも教える お金っていうのは使ってはいけませんよと
使うと減りますよ アリ塚見なさいよと
あるいは砂一粒一粒持ってきて
巨大なアリ塚作ってるんではない
アリ塚ですか シロアリのね
で それからこの目に何か薬をつけるんですよ
インドの女の人も 目の中ではなくて
このまぶたのあれ なんていうか線がありますね
そこら辺に それがこの薬でもありまして
目にはすごくこの のは美しく見えるんですね
目にはすごくいい薬で
それから色は黒いんだから
一般的に綺麗にも見える
お化粧みたいな感じで
今みたいにお化粧だと思って毒をつけるということはしません
それがすごい高価なものなんです
そこでほんのちょっとしか塗れませんね
しかし あれはほんのちょっと塗っても終わりますよ
あの薬は 目のまぶたにつける薬はほんの僅かしか使わないんだけど
終わりますよ だからそれぐらいでお金使ってはいけません
減るんだよ そんな教えで
この子にもろくな何も食べ物もくれないのは当たり前で
病気になっちゃったんですね
病気もそんな面白くない病気ではなくて
あの 何て言いますか 栄養失調
子供はすごい早く栄養失調にかかりますからね
大人と違って 倒れちゃって
それで医者は呼ばない
医者が来たら家の財産見ると高い給料を要求するんだよと
自分が医者のところに行っていろいろ世間話をする
世間話をするなら 先生はいろんなことを知ってますから
なんか例えばなんかこんなこんな感じの病気だったらね
これはどんな病気だと思いますかね
その場合は大体どういう薬はよろしいでしょうかねとかね
医者もそれはもうそれぞれにいい加減で大雑把で
もしかするとこういう病気かもしれません
それにはこういうこういう薬とかね
ありますから とかね 言っちゃうと調合はわからない
作り方はわからない とにかく言ってるものは自分で
まあインドの薬っていうのはこのまあいろんな薬草しか使いませんからね
それはどこにもある そんなものは飲ませる
で さらに病気がひどくなる
それで間もないうちに子供が死ぬ
死んだところで すごく悲しくなっちゃって
ずっと泣いてるんです
お墓に行って 何も食べないで
まあそこでまあ これエピソードはこういうエピソード
それでまあ死ぬことになったら
父親が子供は玄関の方に入れておいたんです
ベッドに寝かせておいたんです
で 外で亡くなったらそのままお墓に持っていくんであって
家の中には親戚が入らなくても大丈夫です
家の中で部屋で亡くなったならば
みんなその子供を見るために家の中に入る
家の中に入っちゃうと
家にあるあまりにも財産があることはもう親戚にバレちゃうということで
子供はやっぱり治らないみたい
ところで外へ置いといて
外へ置いたところで釈尊がそちらに行ったんですね
ただ釈尊が外へ回ったところで
いきなり釈尊の光がね
もう黄色い衣を着ているんだからね
さっと壁に映ったんです
なんでこの光って明るさっていうと
周ってみたら ものすごい落ち着いて
すごい美しい姿で いわゆるお釈迦様を見たんですよ
自分の目で それで なんという人でしょうかと
なんで素晴らしいですかと
ものすごく感動するんですね
すごく感動する 釈尊が見た人は誰でもものすごい感動したんですよ
見ただけで 心落ち着いたら悟り開いたらそういうものすごい力なんです
それ その感動した瞬間で釈尊がこの子にはこれぐらいで十分でしょうと
言ってお帰りになったんですけど
そのままその子は息を止めたんです
息を止めた瞬間で 誰 父親に対しても
誰に対しても 怒りも何も出る余地がないんですよ
もう感動で体がいっぱい
子供っていうのはとても簡単に感動するんだからね
また逆に感動してしまっちゃうと
もう何もわからなくなっちゃうんです
興奮するっていう感動というかね
その子はものすごい興奮したそのままでもう亡くなったんだから
心には何の怒りも憎しみも悩みも悲しみも何もないきれいな心で亡くなったんです
それで天界に生まれ変わっちゃうんです
天界に生まれたところで
なんで私はこちらにいるんでしょうかと
何かいいことでもしたんですか？と言ったら
何もいいことをしていないんですね
ただ お釈迦様を見て興奮してしまっただけ
感動しただけ それだけでこんなに結果になるんだったらということでね
父親は何なのかといえば
父親のことはよく見えたんですね
やっぱり父親は道が間違っているんだと教えてあげなくちゃいけないんだと思って
それがもうこの  1週間ぐらい泣いてたと話でね
自分がこの子供の体を自分の力で作って
いわゆる子供に変身してお墓に行ったんです
お墓に現れたんです 現れてものすごいご泣きするんです
この父親もボロ服を着て 1週間目になっていて
もうご飯も何も食べてないし
お墓に行って泣いてるんですね
泣いてると 子供の泣き声はかなり
遠くいくんだから あまりにも子供がご泣きしているのを見たら
本当は自分の子供と同じ顔形で現れたんですよ
[背景音楽]自分の子が死んだっていうことを知ってるんだからね
まあ何もびっくりすることはないし
しかし 心がなんかすごく変わっちゃうんですよ
そこで自分の悲しみは置いておいて
君なんで泣いてるのと
言ったら 私はこのおもちゃの車欲しいんだよと
だから車といっても今日本にある車と違って
昔の馬車とかそういうものだから
車輪 2つの車ですよ  二輪車ですよ
といっても自転車ではありません
で おもちゃの車一つ欲しいんですよ
と言ってものすごく泣く
いくらなんでもそんなことでそこまで泣くんだったらもうあげたくはなりますね
こんなケチな父も君そんなに泣くなよと
一つあげますよと言ったら
この子はそう簡単ではありませんと
あなたにできませんと
何言うんですか これは一つではなくて
百でもあげられますよと言ったら
実はおじいさん 私にはこの車輪にはこの月と太陽をつけてほしいんです
他の車輪はダメですよ
おもちゃにはおもちゃの車に
でなきゃ嫌だと言ってまた泣き始めたんです
もうどうにもならん あまりにも泣く
それでこの人がね あのね
いくらなんでもこれはできることではありませんと
普通のおもちゃで遊んだらどうですか？と言ったら
この子はいきなりおじいさんも泣いてるでしょ
なんで泣いてるんですか？と
私は泣いてる 子供に子供はあんたバカなことを言ってるんではなくて言われたんですね
言ったらあんたなんで泣いてるんですか？私は私の息子が亡くなって
それですごく悲しくて泣いてるんだと
そしたらあなたの方が私よりバカやと
なんで私にバカと言うんですか？と
私には見えますよと 太陽と月様は
私は目に見えるものを欲しがっているんだよと
あんたなんですか？と
目にも見えないものを返ってこいよと言って泣いてるんではないかと
だから自分が大馬鹿者では人に向かってバカと言ってはいけませんよと言ったところで
君は誰ですか？と聞いたら
私はこういうこういうものだよ
だからあなたの生き方は間違っているんだと
で まあブッダに会ってね
説法を聞いてみなさいよと
そうするとあなたに生きる道が見つかりますよと
で 教えてあげたんですね
それからその人はちゃんとブッダの話を聞くようになりました
で まあなんでそのエピソードを言ったんですかというと
我々はおじいさんみたいに
この決してありえないことを期待して努力するんですよ
それはあんまり智慧の生き方だとは思わないんですね
年取ることがないようにと
病気になることはないようにと
死ぬことはないようにと踏ん張っています
それがあまりにも無知な生き方ですと
もうちょっと待ちに考えてなさいと
ですから この何でも変化する
物質も変化する しかし
物質の変化っていうのを知れたもんですよ
そんなちょっと知識あれば
ほんのちょっと学校に行って勉強してみれば
物質はどうなるものかということは知ってるんでしょうに
だからそこが我が儘で変化させようということで頑張っても
それほどうまくいくわけじゃないんですね
しかし 心は違うんですよ
心は見事に改良することはできます
心はもう改良を待っているような状態なんです
改良してさせてしてくれと
心はもう必死で期待しているんですよ
そこは心の勉強をお釈迦様しかしてないんだから
世界では 心っていうのはどこまででも成長することはできるんだからね
そこら辺に頑張ってくださいと
精神的に優れた人間になるように努力しなさいというのは一応決まりなんですね
だから私はダメという場合は
そのポイントを考えてほしいんですよ
六十歳なのに二十歳の人々をやっていることをやろうとするのはもう無意味ですね
私はもう六十歳だからそんなことはしませんよと
その場合はもうダメだと言っても構いません
それはダメというわけじゃなくて
事実を言っているだけだからね
それは決して自分を捨てているわけじゃないんです
六十歳だからね 君らはこの二十歳の人やっていることをできるわけないんではないかと
そんなことにチャレンジもしませんよと
あなた方の骨折したっても
すぐ一週間で治りますけど
こちらは一ヶ月間ですよ
あるいは二ヶ月間ですよ
ということで それは別に私がダメということじゃないんですよ
世の中で私がダメという方々はこの自分の性格に対して言ってるんですよ
この私がダメダメだと泣いてる方々にものすごい新しいお化粧品がありますけど
これものすごく素晴らしいですよと
肌が元に戻りますよと言っちゃうと平気で使います
だからこの私がダメという考え方はすごくおかしいんでしょうし
それは邪見であるし 思ってはいけない
人間は捨てたものではありません
日々成長しなくちゃいけないということは
もう徹底的に心に入れておかないといけないんですよ
だから仏教の世界はそういう世界で
ただ看板だけかけて 私は仏教徒だよとかね
言ってもそれは表札に過ぎないんですよ
看板なくてもいいんです
日々努力しなくてはいけないということは
一応仏教の基本的な考え方にはなっています
ちょっと内容は長いんだから
もうほぼ一時間ぐらい喋りましたので
少々五分休みましょう
はい それでは始まります
それから皆様に報告しているテーマの内容いくつかあります
で 悪い癖やら習慣から抜け出せず
同じ失敗を繰り返していることやら
人生は改革というではなくて
悪にしてしまうことという羽目になると
いわゆる昨日より今日は頑張りますということは誰でもあるんだけど
なんでなかなかそうならないのかっていうところですよ
ポイントとしては発表して
ところは それでこの一応あの書いて送ってもらった内容がいくつかございます
で 大体現代の人々が あの
どのようにこの自分を良くしようというところを考えているんでしょうかと
よくあることというか
合理的に便利に快適にという
何でも合理的に より便利に快適にしようではないか
それが自分の改革プログラムだと思ってるんですね
結局それは自分に対して合理的ではなくて
まあ物を作るときはより合理的にとか
まあいろんな機械やら電気製品
電化製品というんですか
電気製品 電化製品とかね
いろんなものを見ると
まあ改良改良とかね より合理的に
よくスピーディに よく便利にとか
そういうことを言っていて
しかし自分の方は見てないんですね
だから自分がそのままで機械だけ合理的になると
非合理的な人間がどうやって合理的な機械使うかっていうとね
さらに困ったりするんですよ
まあ次にこの まあ早く
何でも早くやりたがる
で 食べ物の場合はもっと美味しく
もっと美味しくと 人間頑張ってますよ
もっと美味しく食べなくちゃ
で だったらもうもう美味しく安く
こちらに例で入ってました
あのえーと 吉野家の牛丼
で まあそういう結果なんですね
美味しく早く安くという
で またもうまたあれはあまりわかりませんだけど
高く大きく速くと まあうちらの音楽なんか例に出してますけどね
特にまあ男の人々 若者がね
色々音楽やったりして
あまりにも強烈な音で
まあ高温で またものすごい速く派手にという
今あまりにも早口で何言ってるかともうもうあっさりもわからない歌でしょうしね
それがかっこいいという風にね
そこら辺にチャレンジするんです
まあ女性の場合になってくると
まあ美しく綺麗に よりかっこよくとそれに頑張ってるんです
だから結局自分の改革プログラムとして考えてるのはそんなもんですよ
私は良くなりたいと思う女性が何考えてるかと
美しく より美しく より綺麗に
よりかっこよく見せること
まあそれで まああらゆる美容やらファッションやらね
いろんなアートやらね
ネイルアートまでやりますからね
で あれ綺麗かどうか まあ実物見たことがないんですけど
たまにテレビで見ると
あんなものはね 爪をね
すごく長くつけて いろいろ色やら色はいいんですけど
まあ目が慣れてますけど
いろんなものをつけちゃいますね
うーん まあ本人には美しいでしょうね
それでまあ中年になってくると
元気に健康で それまた力強くという目的が出てくるんですね
それで大変なことに あらゆるスポーツジムやら健康法やら最新の色やら
もうまあ次から次へと出てくるんです
それから健康食品といえばもうキリがないんですね
で そういう風に人間っていうのは
まあ改革改良プログラムを考えているんです
仕事の世界では上達とかね
まあ習得するとかね 何かスキル
スキルアップですか スキルアップと
まあそういうものを考えて
だからいろんなスクールがありましてね
まあ能力 スキルアップということのために
まあいっぱいマニュアル本がありますね
いろんなもののマニュアル本というのはいくらでもあります
まあアドバイザーたちがいて
そのような改良計画っていうのは明らかに自分の改良ではないんですね
よくよく見ると逆結果になっちゃうんでしょ
痩せる薬を飲んで死ぬ
健康食品食べて早く腸がんやら胃がんやらね
なって早く死ぬと 医療技術は発展すればするほど医療ミスで
医者ももう手に負えないんですよ
もう進行激しくて だから機械の使い方わからない
かわいそうですよ 一つの機械
例えば 1,000万とか払って導入しても
3ヶ月間でもう新しい機械がもうできているんですよ
まだあれの使い方を習ってないんですよ
で 新しい機械入れなくちゃいけないんです
それで患者さんがお金払わなくちゃいけないし
1,000万円の機械買っても
もう患者さんがまあ 200
300人ぐらいしかもしかすると診ていない
その収入で機械のお金が入りませんからね
まだ新しいものを入れなくちゃいけないし
それ新しい機械だからもう手に負えないんですよ
また だから医療関係の人々っていうのは
まあどうやってるか どうなってるかもう心配でたまらないんですよ
もう患者さんのことをもう考える余裕暇がないんです
もう新しい機械に慣れることっていうのも大切ですからね
だから医療ミスなんかはもう全く不思議でも何でもないんです
それでみんな美味しく早く食べたいでしょ
だからみんなコンビニの
何入れているか本当にわからない
どういう風に作ったら
これはもう大量生産だから
だからもう小さな小さなご飯の小さな量で
まあ女性向きにいろんなものを作って作ってあるんですけど
見るとこんなの食べたらどうかなというね
まあ私は思いますけどね
だから結局逆になっちゃって
美しくおいしいところじゃなくて
もうものすごくもう体に悪いというかね
私は昨日も何回もこのよく行きますから
コンビニはそばにありまして
昨日牛乳買おうと入りましたけど
ドアを開けた瞬間で来るあの匂いでもう入っちゃう気持ちになるんです
全部食べ物の匂いなんです
それぐらい気持ち悪い匂いがするのに
これ私の体の調子かどうかも分かりませんだけど
私もものすごいヘトヘト
頭がお腹が空いたらね
匂いとは思えないしね
だから自分のことはあんまり信頼できませんだけど
いくら臭い匂いがしたっても食べますから
その時は あまり大きなこと言えませんだけど
やっぱりものすごい体が拒絶反応を起こしちゃいますよ
それはみんな毎日のように食べていると
だからよりより良くなろうと思ってどうなっているかと結果はね
そう 全て逆結果になっているんではないかと
そういう女性がね 美しく見せようと思うことでね
あんまりにもいい加減な考え方である
どうにもならない精神的な病気になるでしょ
例えばこの過食症やら拒食症でしたっけ
二つありますね あれは精神的にイカれていますよ
別にもともとイカれたわけじゃないんですよ
立派な可愛い女の子たちですよ
立派で元気で明るくて
うるさいほど明るくて
遊んでいる女の子たちなんですけど
ちょっと年頃になってくると
まだまだ体が小さいなのに痩せなくちゃいけないんだと
ある女の子が 女の子じゃないんですけど
まあ二十歳とんではいるんですけどね
いろいろ痩せたい痩せたいということで
私は見る限りにお前もうちょっと食いなさいと言いたいんですけどね
仕事もなんか幼稚園かどこかなど
すごい体力必要でしょうし
だからこのなかなか仕事できないんだと
疲れて疲れてて当たり前でしょうに
それにもっと痩せたいと
言ったら 私はまあ一応女性の考え方っていうのは知ってるんだからね
言ってはいけませんと
聞くもんじゃない 人の話聞かないんだからね
おだててくる それで終わりっていうようなこと知ってますから
何も言わなかったんですけど
でも逆におだてたんですね
私から見ればね すごい可愛い
可愛くて綺麗ですけど
そしたらお父さんもいて
まあ私はもうこれより痩せちゃうと困りますよと
で まあ大の男二人がそう言う
もう怒られちゃったんですね
何言ってるんですか？と
まあ自分が太りすぎやと
まあしょうがないんだから
まあ私はそこで あんたね
体がどこら辺痩せたいんですか？と
そしたらもう私に怒ることできません
だからお父さんにもカンカン怒って言いたい放題のことを言いながらね
顔を見てくださいと 自分の顔がもう大きすぎやと
全然大きくなんでもないんですけど
すごくスマートで体にぴったしの顔なんですよ
これがアゴが見えて こうやって細くなっちゃうとね
まあ気持ち悪いと思いますけど
本人はそうなりたいんですね
だから顔だけ痩せてくれないんだからね
それでご飯食べないというと
もう体が疲れて食べ力がなくて
仕事もできなくなって
全部台無しになっちゃうんですよ
特に栄養が入らないとすごくイライラするでしょうし
そこで怒ったり いろんなことをしたり
ヤケになっている だからかわいそうに
人生は最悪の方向に持っていっちゃうんですよ
だから良くなりたいという気持ちが
結局は最悪の結果を作ってくれるんですね
だから人間は私が良くなりたい
良くなりたいとやってはいるんだけど
全部結果が仇になっちゃうというか
仇になって返ってくる
そうするとさらにヤケになって
さらに同じ道で頑張る
そこが精神的な病気なんですね
もっと美味しく食べよう食べようと思っちゃうと
もうどんどんもう食べてはいけない
どこまでなんて言っちゃうのか食べ物が
食べ物にはそう遊べないんですよ
人間病気になるのも食べ物のせいだから
糖尿病であろうと高血圧であろうが
何であろうとも 我々は毒食べてるわけじゃないでしょうに
毎日美味しい食べ物食べてるでしょうに
それで体も病気になって衰えて死んでしまいますから
その食べ物といい加減遊んじゃうと
体を支える部分ではなくて
体を壊す部分しか残らないんですね
面白いこと 美味しくすると美味しくしようとする過程で食べ物持っている健康を維持する部分も我々は捨てるんですよ
まあわかりやすく言えば
リンゴを食べるんだったら皮ごとで食べればいいのに
美味しくないんだから
硬いんだからということで皮を厚く剥く
でもリンゴにある栄養分というのは皮の上にのってるんです
悪いことに真ん中はただの水と砂糖だけ
リンゴも甘いもので 自分も身を守らなくちゃいけないんだから
いろんなものから だからこの健康を維持する身を守るもの
細胞を守る成分っていうのは全部皮のちょっとちょっと前でずっとあるんです
ジャガイモも同じなんです
で 我々は厚く剥いて綺麗に綺麗なもう菜の芽いろんなね
細切りにしたり いろんな形にして
もう美しく美味しく食べるということで
毒を食べることになっちゃうんです
まあいわゆるデンプンとかは入ってるのは入ってるんだけど
それだけでは体が壊れちゃいます
もう細胞もガードしてあげないとその成分は全部捨てちゃいますね
だからできればリンゴを木から取って
そのままね 部分で拭いて食べた方が一番いいです
それが品が悪いんですね
このキュウリとかね そのまま取ってちょっと手で磨いて拭いて
そのまま食べれば もうかなり体には良いんです
し それが本当に美味しいんですよ
この細胞が守られるなと感じちゃうと
ものすごく美味しく感じるんです
今は妄想ですからね これは形悪いとかね
だからこの体のことではなくて
妄想のことで食べたりするんですから
この健康健康やと言いながら
結局 健康そのものを壊す道を歩んでいる
電化製品やらいろんなものを作って
より便利に より便利にといってはいるんだけど
結果としてどんどん不便になる
この間 この京都の瞑想カイト法禅寺でテレビがあって
いきなり映らなくなっちゃったんです
私が診たところで こんなちょっとのところがちょっとイカれてるんです
ほんのちょっとの問題なんです
それはこの電気は繋げますが
この電気ユニットがこの TV ユニットに電気を伝えてあげないんです
その分ちゃんと仕事をする
両方仕事はします この伝達はしてくれない
ほんのちょっと IC か何かちょっとイカれてるだけで
まあそれは値段で言ってもほとんどこの部品って百円 二百円いかないんですよ
しかし 誰が修理するんですかね
そんなの 誰もいない それで電気屋さんが来て
あ やっぱり私が言った通り
ここら辺にまあ腕がないんだと
では 新しい機械買ってくださいと
結局新しいテレビを入れたんですね
便利な世界なんですよ
まあもうせいぜいあの技術料を払っても
これ二万円ぐらいで それ修理すれば自然も守られるし
ゴミもないし でもあまりにも便利な世界で
そんな修理する人っていうのはいません
その代わりに新しい機械を買わなければいけない
それでまた無茶な値段で
今我々実際に使っている機械っていうのは
ほとんどもう便利か不便かどちらか分からない
という状態になってはいるんですよ
洗濯機にしてもね 全部完璧に洗って干してまで作ってくれるというと
もう人間の手は出すところなくなっちゃう
だから勝手に洗いますから
それでよろしいかと 例えば
まあある服は長い時間洗ってほしいし
これはほんのちょっともう洗うだけでよろしいかと言ったっても
途中では開けられません
完全に まだまだ皆様使ってないと思いますけど
このもう洗って干してくれる機械の場合
それっきりもう開けられません
出ていけと という感じ
はい そういうことで この本当に人間が良くなりたいと思っているんですか？という疑問が出ているんですよ
人間というのは自分のことを見ようとしない
より良い人間になろうと思っても
もう部品がもういろんな機械の開発やら
例えば食べ物を改良するっていうことはありますね
それは例えばね たとえ話で
もっと美味しく もっと軽く
もっとというのも軽じゃなくて
柔らかいものを食いたい食いたいと言ってもね
それよりはあるものに体を慣らしてちゃえ
習わせちゃえばどうですか
すぐ体が習ってしまいますよ
体にそういう能力があるんです
自然 自然に適応する能力っていうのは
それはもうとっくに失っているんですよ
本当に自分を良くしたければ
環境に自分を合わせる
食べ物に自分を合わせる
そうするとそんなに苦労はないと思います
そうすると 外国旅行する時はたくさんインスタントラーメンを持って行かなくても済みます
高級ホテル泊まって部屋でインスタントラーメン食べると
という羽になっているのは
やっぱり体がもう合わない
合わせないんですね だから結局なんか変なことをやっている結果になっちゃうんですね
それにまた気づかないんですね
なんでたまたま外国に行く場合
みんなちょっと ちょっと無理をして贅沢するでしょうに
ちょっといいホテルを選んだりとかね
ちょっとカッコつけて
まあその気分の楽しみだから金持ちのようなふりをしたりとかね
なのにラーメン 持っていって
すごい高級ホテルでラーメン食べたってあまり自慢にはなりませんですけどね
自慢になるんです だったら何で行ったんですか？とか
あのホテル代は何なのかと
食事代まで払ってるの
借金までして だからこの
それちょっと具体的な例を出しただけで
やっぱり我々は肉体 体にしたっても
自然に適応するという能力を持っているんですよ
パンダと違いますからね
人間はもっと頑固 頑固ですよ
から頑固じゃない 何て言いますか
もっと強いんですよ かなり適応能力持ってます
それは見事に自分で放棄している
パンダと同じ状態になっちゃって
完全に守ってあげないと人工的に繁殖しないとパンダがもう子供は作れませんね
今 中国で頑張ってますからね
そんなことをしたってもね
もう てますか？絶滅になっている危機危機からね
パンダを救いましょうと言ったっても
我々あれで救ったことになるのかと
ずっと人工的に繁殖させて
そういう施設で育てて
もうパンダは一応いることはいるんですけど
結局自然に自分の勝手に繁殖できなかったらもうダメですよ
人間も同じ状態になっている
まあ人工的な環境でないと生きていられないという
だから 例えば私は今言ったのは
仮に世間の改良計画を見てねともやり方が違うんじゃないかと
これある食べ物を見て
これはどんな工夫すれば
どのように工夫すればおいしくなるかではなくて
それがおいしく感じられる
感じられるような自分の体を変えればどうですかと
そうすると体は成長しますよ
だから道はそういう道なんですよ
例えば顔がね まあすごく肌が荒れて肌荒れいろいろあってね
困ります 困りますというならば
あらゆるものを持って
このもういろいろ体を被っても隠すんじゃなくて
そうすると細胞死ぬんですよ
早くなるんです 老化現象が
できれば体にも習いなさい
自然の問題っていうのは寒くなったり
暑くなったり ほこりが溜まったりするのはあなたのお仕事だよと
そうしちゃうと もう細胞が生き返ってきて元気になるんですね
誰もそれをしようとはしない
で 全くお化粧しない女性の方々は年取っても顔が綺麗ですよ
でも若い時見たらなんだこれって皆様思うかもしれませんだけど
見たことはないんだからね
自然の顔っていうのは
しかし そういう人々は年取ってもあの顔の方が荒れることも何もなく
まあしわは出ますけどね
それはもうどうにもならんことでね
でもまあ気持ち悪い状態にはなりません
まあやっぱりそういうことから見ても
私たちは体で 適応能力を持つべきなのに
それを置いておいて物に頼るという
そうすると当然こちらの能力はなくなる
ということは改良ではなくて
逆に行ってます では 次にあの
まあ仏教からどういうふうに答えればいいかということはね
俗世間の考え方 例えば何でもかんでも合理的にやりたがる
それは悪いことではありません
便利にしたいと快適にしたいというのは
それはそんなに悪いことではないんですね
例えばこの 物事を合理的にやりたいというならば
何が必要ですかね 合理的に考えるのは私でしょうに
だから私の思考を改良するんですよ
非合理的に物事を考えないように性格を作ってみれば
外のどんな機械開発したっても
すぐ合理的に自動的に合理的になるんです
だから頭が合理的だったら
周り環境っていうのは何の苦労もなく自動的に合理的になるんです
頭が全く合理的じゃなくて
ぐちゃぐちゃ状態で一生懸命何かこれをどうすればいいか
これをどうすればいいかと考えるんだから
もうあまり合理的になりません
だから正しい改良っていうのは
自分がもう完全に合理的になるっていうことなんですね
だから合理的また理解してないんですよ
もうものすごく嫌な理屈っぽくなることを合理的だと思います
それは合理的ってわけじゃないんです
ものすごくいやらしい理屈っぽい人間になるんですね
よく見てください そういう人は理屈ばっかり言ってるんだけど
まるっきり非合理的なんです
たまに私はこれ見せてあげたくなるんだけど
狂暴だから向こうはね
非論理的に侮辱してもういろんなことを始めちゃうと
こちらはもうそこは付き合いませんだからね
だから時々面白くなって
この人は合理のつもりですけど
では見せてあげようかなと
言ってもそれすらもできないんですよ
言っちゃうと向こうは腹が立って
もう誹謗中傷やら何から何まで始めちゃうと
同じことを言い返すわけにいきませんしね
こちらが汚れてしまいますからね
黙ってなきゃいけない
そうすると私が負けたと
ということにもなります
それは構いませんですけど
やっぱりこの ただ合理的っていうのは
ものすごくいやらしく
理屈っぽくなることではなくて
ちゃんと合理的って それは合理的なのはすごく面白くて
みんな驚きますね さすがという気持ちになるんですね
例えば 誰かが本当に合理的に物事をやっていると
見るのが楽しいんですよ
驚きの連続になっちゃうんですね
だからそういう合理なんですよ
だから合理的っていうのはもう完全に無駄をなくして
ちゃんと問題を発見して
その問題にこれが答えですと
ですから 合理的な生き方はもうお釈迦様が推薦している正しい生き方なんですけど
物に合理を言うんじゃなくて
自分の心 自分自身が無駄な思考をしない
役に立たない思考をしない人間になってみる
だから答えはとっても簡単です
無駄な思考をしないこと
何か考えるならば ちゃんとデータに基づいて客観的にそれを考えて結論出して
それで終わっちゃう 引きずる思考だったら無駄ですよ
なんかどうしても忘れられないとか
他の考え方 どうせ引きずって引きずっていくんだったら
これは明らかに妄想であって
自分をダメにするんですよ
だから何があってもさっさと考えて
はい終了終わったということにしないと
思考が引きずる状態になっちゃうと
それがもう良くない思考で
まあ論理的ではないんです
だから無駄な思考をやめると
それ無駄な思考をやめる方法っていうのは一つ方法あります
こんなことを考えたら私のためになりますかと
私は幸福になりますかと
すぐ自分に問いてみてください
何か考え方を引きずっちゃって
もうどうにもならん状態になってくると
それは病気になってお医者さんのところに行くまで持っていかないで
瞬時にこんなことを考えたら私のためになるんでしょうかと
今自分が考えることが役に立ちますかないか
自分が幸福になるかならないか
この考え方は他人に迷惑かないか
それでそれだけで自分に問いてみると
その思考はそこでストップしてくるということです
皆様はもう慣れてることだから
お金にはすごい厳密すぎでしょうに
10円でも品物を安く売ってるんだったら
これだったら 1kg でも平気で買ったりするし
で まあそれぐらいお金にものすごい厳しいんだったら
そんなに厳しくなくてもいいんです
お金の場合は 思考に何で厳しくないんですか？全て思考から現れますからね
生き方は ですから 思考は一番ケチった方がいいんです
それを覚えて実践してみてください
思考は無料やと思ったの？無料ではないんですよ
ものすごいお金かかってるんです
全て無駄にお金行ってるのは思考のせいなんですよ
だからまあ分かりやすく言えば
日本の経済状態もなかなか立ち直らない
どこまで これは考えられない状態です
経済的に最高の位置にいて
どうにも立ち直らない状態に陥ってしまったというのはね
なんのことね これ思考なんですよ
だから思考はどれほど損するかと
無駄な思考で 役に立つ思考はありません
でした 今もない だからもう怪異なんて立ち直ることも想像つかないんですよ
今もそういう関係の方々の思考を見ると
国のためとか経済のためじゃなくて
自分のことしか考えてないんでね
自分の権力やら立場やら
ああ ダメだよこんな思考だったらという風に私たちは関係ないと思ってしまいますけどね
まあこちらが楽だから考えると
とにかく我々は一番ものすごく気をつけてケチった方がよろしいんですよ
思考をケチった方が これはすごい危険で
だから有効なことのみを考える
考えて急に止まる はい
終わった 結論出してすぐ終わっちゃう
それで考える時も何を考えてますかと
それに考えるためにいろいろデータが必要ですからね
そのデータの範囲でそこまで考えるしかないかどうかね
間違った思考と人を不幸に導くことを勉強したければ
テレビのワイドショーとかニュースの解説とか見てください
いかに思考がおかしい
間違って好き勝手なことを言うかと
それがもうマスコミだからね
そういうのみんな操られてしまう
で もう本当に昨日もすごい気持ち悪くなっちゃった
何かにそれなんか誰かがこの人は何言ってるんですか？と
勝手な妄想 公の電波を使って言うなよと
これで人がダメになっちゃいますよ
そういうのをよくちょっと観察して見てみると見えてくるんですよ
本当にデータも何もないのに作り立てることっていうのは
一旦マスコミで作り立ったものは情報ない我々はその通りだと思ってしまうんです
だからただニュースで言ったんだからと解説で言ったんだからといって
そのまま聞くんじゃなくて
この人にデータがあるんでしょうか
あるんでしょう データを余計にどんな風に解説してるんでしょうかとか
例えば誰かが犯罪を起こしたならば
もう逮捕されるでしょうね
それから何を調べるかってさっぱりわからない
それは厳密に秘密にしているんだから
日本の警察は しかし この人はこう言った
なんでこう言う？どういうわけでこう言ってるんだ
だからこうなる だからこうなるとかね
よく喋ること 何一つも証拠ないのに
取り調べはその人が何言ってるか全然言ってくれないんですよ
マスコミに そこで審判までする
それは終わりましたと
終わっていないんです
何年もかかりますけど
実際の審判には とにかく私たちはこのまあ
時間なくなりますから
いろいろ無駄な思考していて
それで頭が混乱して何も考えられない状態になっている
ですから 本当は 20時間考えてる思考っていうのは 20時間かかりません
ほとんど 2 3分で考えて終了することはできます
だから思考をケチった方がいいんですよ
いわゆる役に立たない思考は絶対しませんと
実行できない思考 役に立たない思考
自分を悲しませる思考
自分を混乱させる思考
いくらでもあるでしょう
自分を落ち込ませる思考
そんなのをまとめて私は妄想と言うんだからね
あれかデータに支えてないんだから妄想なんですよ
例えば私はダメダメな人間やと思っちゃうと
そんなこと言われても私は大体聞かない
妄想にはついていけませんだからね
どうしても向こうはもう引きずるんだけど
あなたも参加しなさいと
と言うならば あんたもう何でダメですか？と
何がダメですかと はっきり具体的にしなさいと
なぜそんな風に思うようになった？ちゃんと証拠を出してください
証拠を要求する そうすると明らかに自分たちがもう頭が悪いということが見えてくるはずなんです
なぜならば 何かをやって
それをうまくいかなかった故に私がダメですということだから
だから これこれがあなた全部ですかと
何かをして失敗したんだからといって
それは何か一つの出来事でしょうに
で 考えてみたら 人間やっていることは何でも成功するんですから
我々はいろんなことにチャレンジするんだけど
成功するのはもう 1000分の1ぐらいのものでしょうね
それも多い方 素晴らしい方
1万分の1ぐらいのことですよ
成功するのは だから ある一つの失敗を見てね
私がダメと そんなに屁理屈というかね
非合理的な思考っていうのはあるんですかと
まあこれがやりました
これはダメでしたと 次にこれがうまくいったと
これがまあまあで これがまたダメでしたっていう連続でしょう
人生は これもっとあの怖い例えで考えてください
子供が二人がいるとします
で 一人が病気になってしまって
あるいはもう病気にならなくてもいいけど
あるいはもう事故で自転車で遊びに行くぞと言ったところで
車にはねられて死んでしまったと
それで私がダメと 不幸やと
決めるんじゃないんですよ
といったら母親が言う
あの一番可愛い可愛い子供でしたとかね
次の子は可愛くないんですかと聞きたいんですけどね
あれやこれやと思いながら
私がダメでしたと なんて不幸ですかとか
そこで全部もう人生それからダメになっちゃうし
残っている子供の面倒も見られなくなっちゃうし
だから まあ元気でいたその子はもう大人にすることはできませんでした
ある一定その仕事は失敗で
次の仕事に行くぞと 実際は論理的にというのはそんなもんですよ
死んだ子は戻ってくるわけでもないし
悲しがったって何の得にもなりませんし
だから これは一番強烈な例えで
他の我々が出会う不幸っていうのはそれほどすごいじゃないでしょうに
一番ショックを受けて受けちゃうのは
そういうことを子供が死んじゃったとか
そういう時でしょうに
だから それでも余計なことを考えないで
きちんと私はダメだと変なことを思わないで
もうこれは役に立たない思考だと思って
綺麗にそこでストップした方がよろしいんですね
それは日常生活の中で我々が出会う不幸というのは
それほど大それた大胆なことではありません
そういう単純な不幸なんかには
まあ余計な妄想をしない方がよろしいんじゃないかなと思いますね
そこでかなり 時間は残ります
この残り時間で何しますかと
では 極力思考をケチっちゃうと
忙しい忙しい時間がないという人々にとっては
ものすごい時間残るんですよ
なんで忙しいんですかというと
すごく時間を無駄に使っているからなんです
あまりにも妄想に時間がかかるんですよ
だから掃除 洗濯でもう一日
料理で一日終わるんですよ
もう大変なことをやっている
料理と洗濯と買い物と掃除と
これで終わりますよ それで体も壊れるし
ものすごい一日中無駄な思考
妄想しているんです それさえなければ
このスピーディーに何でもやりたいでしょうに
それですごいスピードが生まれてきます
何も妄想しないでジャガイモの皮を剥くこと
それからいろんなことを考えながら皮を剥くこと
どちらが早いんですかね
何のことも考えないと淡々と料理を作る
あれやこれやとか 子供はまだ帰ってないんだ
旦那はまだ帰ってない
何でしょうかとか いろんなことをね
考えながら料理してみてください
どれほど時間なくなるか
いろんなものを頭空にしちゃうんです
その場合 だから思考しないと
もう想像できないほど我々は速くなっちゃうんです
[笑い]それで無駄も消えちゃう
だからなんでもう会社にいろんなところに行ったら早く早くスピーディ
スピーディに色んなこと言ってますか？というと
無駄をなくすということなんですよ
だから無駄をなくせ 無駄をなくせというべきところで
しかし 会社では妄想については何も言えないんだからね
だから本当の原因は見つからないんですよ
なんで人が無駄なことをしますか？と
なんで仕事を失敗するんですか？と
なんでやり直しになるんですか？と
なんでいっぺんにきちんとできないんですか？と
なんで人をオリエンテーションする時でも
いろんな新しい仕事 いろんなことに仕事が変わるって
それまた勉強しなきゃいけないでしょ
それにかかる時間とお金がかかっちゃう
あれは何でしょうかね
すべて妄想のせいですよ
例えば 四十五歳まで何か仕事をして
また会社が生き残るためにいろいろ改良プログラムが入っちゃって
自分が今まで一度もやったことがない仕事分野に回されちゃう
何一つわからないと だったら今までの仕事をした経験もありますから
たとえ仕事内容は全く違うものであろうとも
これは 日二日で慣れるはずなんですよ
それは慣れないんですよ
妄想ばっかりしていて
元に経済状態元に戻ってくれないか
前のように商売繁盛してくれないか
そうすると私は前の仕事にまた戻れるぞとかね
こんな年になって まだなんで私は初めから勉強しなくちゃアカンかとかね
それで 二日で習える 習ってしまえるものというのは
もう何ヶ月かもかかっちゃって
それでも仕事にならなそうすると会社はいい顔をしない
あんたなんかちょっと荷物ではないかなということになっちゃうんですね
それで習わなかったならば
そのままもうお払い箱になってしまう
だから我々に能力ない
勉強できない 新しいものは身につかないとか
いろんなあるのはもう自分ものすごく強烈に自我を作って妄想してるんですね
だから無常の論理に成り立って成り立つというんでしょうか
無常の論理をちゃんと真理だと認めて
もう何でも変化するんだよと
到底見てみれば 勉強も何でもできません
妄想でもう頭がもうクタクタ疲れてるんですよ
全部使用済みになってるんです
だからもう使えない 紙カップに例えれば
部屋いっぱい紙カップあるんだけど
全部使用済みなんですね
水飲みたくなっても部屋いっぱいあるんだけど
水は飲めないんですよ
我々の脳細胞はそんな状態で妄想で全部使用済み
実際に役に立つように使ったわけじゃないんです
だから能力はないんですよ
だからスピーディーにやら早いってやら
いろんなことを まあそういうたった一つ余計な思考をするなかれということで解決します
しかし この出てくる余裕があるんですよ
そうすると もし成功したならば
これだけはどうしますか？で二
三分で考えてしまったならば
普通は一時間もかかるのにとかね
その時間でどうしますかね
その時間でもっと他の役に立つことをすれば
それで人口は人生は成功しないと思いますかね
それでどうしても心を性格を直すために
お釈迦様がこの慈悲の概念
慈悲の思考でね 生きてみなさいと
言ってるんです そこで慈悲の思考で頭が一体になると
無駄な妄想と屁理屈はすべて消えちゃうんです
いろいろ工夫しながら
頭の中で妄想ではなくて
慈悲の思考を回転させるんです
それが皆様に紹介しているのは生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにという文章ですけど
そればっかり回転させちゃうと
なんか面白くないという感じになる方々もいる
その場合はいろいろ工夫しながら面白くそれは回転させる
それは全然妄想ではありません
それが事実ですよ なぜならば私が幸せになりたい
当たり前 しかし それを忘れている人々はいますよ
例えば  一万 二万人に人々から聞いてみると
俺なんか幸せになりたくないぞと言う人もいるかもしれませんよ
しかし 調べてみると そういう人々はちょっとおかしいだけ
ちょっと何か失敗して
何か気に入らないことばっかし人生で起きちゃって
それで頭がおかしくなっている
それで私が私なんかはそんな幸福になりたくないんだぞと言っている人に
だったらあなたは真面目に
真剣に私が不幸になりますようにとしっかりと思ってみなさいよ
その気持ちで生きてみなさいよ
これから徹底的に不幸になりますよと
言うと その人はあれ？と思っちゃいますよ
自分の偽善に気づくんですよ
だからいますよ 世の中で時々ね
そんなのは勉強したくないんです
何のために勉強する？仕事はやりませんよとかね
それで あんたもうお金もなくて
誰が気にするもんか そんなのはとかね
あののはただ病気だけでおかしいんですよ
それだったらどうぞやりなさいと
分かれました しっかりと私が不幸になりますようにと
念じて思って そういうふうに生きてみなさい
言うとあれと気づくんですよ
そこで人間がやっていることは
なぜ無茶苦茶かというと
我々もうにさえも私が幸福になりたいということははっきりしていないんですよ
だから偽善の塊なんですね
人生っていうのは 汚れてますよ
醜くて汚いんですよ 例えば
私は家族のために必死で尽くしましたよとか
家族のために一生懸命仕事をしましたよとか
私は私のことを置いておいて
そんな嘘を言うなかれと
それが頭が混乱しているんです
人のために過ごしたんだったら何で今文句言ってるんですかね
旦那のために過ごして
子供のために過ごして
それで今何様ですか？って
なんで文句 何様になったっていいんだから
自分が作ったんだから
それで十分でしょうに
やっぱり頭が混乱してるんですよ
だから我々はどう生きるべきか
何するべきかはっきりしないんですね
偽善だけの生き方になっています
ほとんどの人間っていうのはね
偽善ですよ 偽善っていうのは汚れているしね
だからその偽善を仏教はまず取り除く
それは私が幸せでありますようにということなんです
私が幸福で楽しく清らかな気持ちで
悩み苦しみのない 生きてみたいものですよ
その気持ちで家族のことやら仕事やらやってみると
すごく気楽ですよ 例えば子供に何かしつけする時でも
こんなことをやめなさい
もう立派な人間に大人になりませんよとか何と言ったっても
子供はあまり聞いてくれない時ありますね
あまりではなくて ほとんど聞いてくれないんですね
その時は正直に本当のことを言ってください
私が嫌ですと あなたをそんなことやる子供は全くも嫌いですと
可愛いとも思えないんだよ
面倒見たくないんだと
正直なところですよ それで言ってみたら
すぐ直ります 聞いてくれます
そんな性格だったら そんな調子だったらね
あなたの面倒見るのは楽しくも何でもないんだと
その上もう可愛くもないんだと
ものすごい嫌ですよ だからあれやめなさいとは言わないんです
まあまず言ってても それはやめた方がいいと
向こうは攻撃する だったら私はもう全くも嫌い
嫌 私にとってはそういう子供っていうのは可愛くもないし
楽しくもないと 見事に治ると思いますよ
時々子供にいろんなことを言うと
大人になったところで子供は逆
何て言いますか 逆襲するときあるでしょうに
あんた方はもういろいろ一生懸命やったりしても
自分たちで散々遊んだんではないかと
子供を可愛がって育てることで
そんなとんでもないことを言う子供もいますからね
ですから それは最初から自分で言ってあげれば
向こうにはもうそれは武器に使うことはできなくなっちゃうんです
とにかくこの私が幸せでありますようにということは事実ですよ
真理ですよ 真理を無視にして
どういうふうに正しい生き方を作れますかね
ですから それをしっかりして
だったら あの人もこの人もあの人も
知ってる人も知らない人も
日本国民も外国人もみんな犬も猫も動物も
あらゆる生命が幸福になりたいと思ってるんだよと
ということは 私が生きる場合は
全ての生命が幸福になりますようにと思わなくちゃ
とんでもない法則違反を起こしてますと
これはとんでもない間違いだと
それでほとんどの問題解決します
民衆問題であろうか 宗教の争いであろうか
もうあらゆる問題 それで解決する
自然の問題も いつでも自分の楽しみと生命の楽しみを考えて行動する
それだけすごく楽しいんですよ
例えば犬の場合は 犬がもう飼われて欲しがってるでしょうに
犬が飼われて楽しいと思ってる
それで親切に愛情を持って飼ってあげれば
犬もまたすごく楽しくなっちゃって
それで互いに楽しいでしょうに
買ってあげた人にも楽しいし
買われた人にも楽しいでしょうに
なんでその楽しみを捨てるんですかね
だからそれは犬と人間の間だけに限ってますね
人間は 人間は犬に向かっては優しいでしょう
イギリス人もそうなんです
人間だったらまるっきりもう差別でもいい加減でもうやりたい放題ですけど
犬の場合はまるっきり違う
そういう犬生できてますけどね
だから仏教でいうのは
やっぱりこれ 犬と人間だけのことじゃなくて
すべての生命に対して関わりですから
あなた方は分かってないんだと
これをどれほど楽しいかと
そういうわけで もうすごく苦しみも消えちゃって
すごく幸福で生活できる
それからこの本当に生命がすべての生命のことを気持ちを思うようになるということ自体が精神的な成長なんですよ
精神的な成長とともに
幸福感がどんどんどんどんどんどんどんどん増えていく
だからこの無駄な思考で苦しんで
自分持っている能力もなくなっちゃって
悪循環でね 行くんではなくて
やっぱり幸福というものを目指して頑張った方がいいっていうのは仏教の世界なんですね
まああの 知恵の開発のために我々はまずいうのは
この思考をやめることと
今の瞬間を観察しなさいということなんですね
それが知恵の開発する方法なんです
今の瞬間を観察する それはヴィパッサナーという実践方法で
それ観察していくと 見事に知恵が現れてきます
歩く時は歩くことを観察する
食べる時は食べることを観察する
他の仕事をするときも
そのその瞬間でやっている仕事を観察する
観察すると 頭には考える暇がないんです
考えることは完全に無駄
不幸になります いわゆる役に立つ思考ではありません
だから そこで考えることはできない状態でいると
新しい発見がありますよ
世の中の仕事がいろいろあります
手でやる仕事 口でやる仕事とかね
で 一部考えてやる仕事もあります
今はそれは何なのかさっぱりわからないはずなんです
だから思考が大事だ 思考が大事だと思っているだけで
そうじゃなくて 思考がなければできない仕事も一部あります
それははっきりしていない
だから何でも考えてやっちゃうんです
考えなくてもいいものまで考えちゃう
だから妄想になっちゃう
そういうことで 歩く時は歩くということをちゃんと観察して歩くと
失敗はなし 無駄はなし
それ食べる時は食べるものをちゃんと観察しながら
味わいながら食べると
食べ過ぎには絶対なりません
体と脳が知ってます 何を食べたかと知ってるんだから
それはどう消化するべきか
どういう風にその栄養を吸収するべきかということは
細胞はもうとっくに知ってるんです
だからお腹が壊したり
おかしくなったりすることは成り立たなくなっている
ということは 自然に食べ物に体が合わせているということなんです
今 妄想で体に食べ物を合わせようとしているんです
しかし 体の状況は何なのかとわかってない
体の状況 分かってない人はどうやって食べ物を合わせるんですかね
そうすると妄想で合わせる
だから失敗して不幸な結果になる
だから食べる時もちゃんと観察して食べると
しかし これが体にいいとかね
そんなことを考えない方がいいんです
それが体にいいというのは嘘で知らないでしょ
誰かさんの話だから だからもうニンジンは体にいい
トマトは体にいい あれが体にいい
これは体にいいよとかね
誰が言ったことですかね
体にいいか悪いか体なんで知らないんですかね
おかしいでしょうね 体
体この体だから体も知らないことは好き勝手に
それは私は勝手に もうあなたはこういう食べ物好きでしょう？と言って勝手に何かあげることと同じなんですよ
子供なんか怒るでしょうね
もう強引にこれあなたにもいいんだからって食べなさいと言ったら
それで体も知らないのに
あれやこれやとかもうもうもう詰め込む
だから食べる時はもう我々はこれが体にいい
これがとか何とかとかね
と思わないで まあ感で味わって食べる
それで体がそれで今日の入れてくれる材料はこういうものだと
この材料の場合はこうするべきだと体が知ってるんです
だからそこは妄想で抑えてはいけません
それでこのもうダイエットの問題も解決するし
でもうほとんど解決します
それで 瞬間瞬間の出来事を観察してみると
妄想が消えちゃう それで私は言ったんですね
見事に知恵が出てくると
それが何なのかと 知恵って何なのかと誰もわからないんですよ
知恵がある人があるかないか発見する方法はあるんです
あんまりぐちゃぐちゃ考えない
何か考えなくちゃいかんことを頭に入ったっていうのも
瞬時にもう消えた いわゆる答えが出て消えちゃう
いわゆる何も考えることのない状態が知恵の状態なんです
それはなんで知恵と言うんでしょうかというと
問題が起きたら瞬時に答えが出るんですよ
この人に だから全然考える必要がないんです
ものすごい大きい問題が起きちゃって
みんな神経質になっちゃって
神経が高ぶってどうしようどうしようかとも頭を抱えて悩んでる時は
ああそうですかねとか
こうすればいいんじゃないかなと何のことなく言う
みんなあんた全然何も考えない
この問題の重大さはわかってないんではないかとか怒るかもしれませんだけど
別にそれはわからなくたってこうすればいいでしょうと
その人は言うんですよ
重大さはわからなくてもこうすればいいでしょうと
必要なのはそれなんですよ
問題に答えなんです 問題に答えを出すためには
もう疲れ果てた脳細胞でできません
機能しないで脳細胞ではできません
ですから このこの実践方法で思考がもう強引に止まって
それから本当のことをわかってくると
思考しなくてもいいんじゃないかということになってくる
それが知恵の知恵があるということなんです
だから知恵っていうのは何か知識みたいに勉強したものみたいに
何か持ち物ではありません
あの知識は皆様のカバンと同じく持ち物ですよ
だからカバン忘れたり
持っているものを忘れたり
盗まれたり 紛失になったりありますね
カバン誰かにもう取ってしまっちゃえば
もうどうしようもないでしょうに
ですから カバンは私のものではないんですよ
人にもうもう持っていかれることもできますからね
覚えておこう 知識も同じなんです
落ちるんですよ あれも持ち物なんです
大事に守っておかないと
皆様方は自分のカバンを大事に守っているような感じで
自転車にカバン入れたっても
なんかチェーンで繋げて持っていったりするでしょうね
そうするともう持っていけませんからね
そういう風に持ち物守るような感じで
知識も守らなきゃ全部落ちるんですよ
いくらたくさん勉強したっても
あれというと全部忘れていると
だから私が言いたいのは
知識も持ち物で知恵ではありません
知恵っていうのは自分ですよ
なんか能力みたいなもので
何か概念ではありません
ですから 智慧が現れてくればくるほど
すごく精神的にどんどん楽になる
考えなくてもいいやと
という気持ちになるんですね
そうなるよりもっと具体的で
ただ自分が悩まない状態にいる
心配しない状態でいる
ということで 智慧の開発が出てくると
人間に自分を成長してあげるということをいとも簡単にできます
えーと まあそろそろ で
あの なんで仏教の人々はそんなに光り輝いて
例えば ある日 森の中で何も持ち物もなくて
あるお坊さんがいたんですよ
森の中で生活して でも見たらものすごいなんか王様の気分で
すごい気持ちよく穏やかで楽しく生活している
ひとかけらの苦しみも何もない
ある人がこれ見て不思議でたまらなかったんです
なんでこの人には何もないのにそんなに楽しく生きているんでしょうかと
逆ではないかと 人っていうのは
あれがあってこれがあって
あらゆるものがあって
立場があって お金があって
権力があって もう家族がいて
いろんなこと言って幸福になろうなろうと頑張っているところで
幸福になるものっていうのは一つもないんではないかと
この人には お金はないわ
食べ物もないわと いるところもない
きれいな服もないんですよと
これがなんですかと なんかすべて完璧に満たしているような感じで
穏やかな顔をしているんではないかと
それで 森にいるあなた方はなんで悩まないのかと
なんで苦しまないのかと聞かれたんです
答えは簡単 妄想しないから
それはあの あるので時間なくなります
はい それで なんでそんなにも幸福満々で苦しみひとかけらもないんでしょうかと聞かれたら
まあこれ全部四行をまとめて答え出しちゃうと
妄想しないからという一言葉なんですよ
では原文でこういうふうにあります
アティータンナームソーチャンティ
過去の過去 過去のことにおいては悩むことをしません
過去のものについては悩むことはしません
ナッパジャッパンティナーゲタン
ナッパジャッパンティ
ナッパジャッパンティっていうのは悶々悶々と考えること
妄想すること ナーゲタン
行って起こってないもの
いわゆる将来について
将来についていろんなぐちゃぐちゃと考えていませんと
過去においても全然悩むことはなし
将来においてもぐちゃぐちゃ考えることはしません
パッチュッパンニーネヤーテンディ
パッチュッパン 今ここにある現実事実だけで生活していますと
今ここにあるものしかもう思考の中に回転させません
今現在のことしかっていうこと
それで生活していますと
テーナワンノーパシー
だからワンノーっていうのはもう体のことで
まあ体の美しさなんですけど
いわゆるこんな我々輝いているんだよと
パシーと我々の体がいうはだから輝いていますよ
いわゆる皆様はもう妄想しないんだから
何の悩みの苦しみもなく
すごく光輝いて生きてるんだよと理解しておけば
まあパーリ語だからね
なかなかまあややこしいんですけど
じゃあ消します これ大量にありますよ
で これがもうもう十二回
十二回やっても終わらないぐらい私はデータ一応持ってます
それぐらいデータが何時間でまとめたというと三十分以内です
だからちゃんと早いっていうのはそういうわけなんです
それはなんで三十分もかかったかというと
コンピューター使ったんだから
もし自分の手でやったならばもっと短い
コンピューター早くて現代の機械だからね
早い だから結構時間かかります
それは反対のことはちょっと覚えやすいんではなくて
理解しやすい  [足音]アナーガタッパジャッパヤ
アティータッサーヌソーチャナー
エーテーナバーラースッサンティ
ナローワハリトーロト
前の偈は何回もこの前に紹介した可能性あります
で これはできれば書いておいて覚えておいてください
それから意味を申し上げます
アナーガタッパジャッパヤ
読み方はそのままローマ字で読めばパーリ語の読み方になります
アティータッサーヌソーチャナー
この上 棒を引いているところは伸ばすんです
それだけ 例えばこっちがアイの上に棒引いてますからティーと読むんです
アティータ アティー ちょっと間違ってます
えーと こっちはないです
アティータッサーヌソーチャナー
エーテーナバーラースッサンティ
ナローワハリトーロト
では意味は これは普通の人のことを言ってます
前はお坊さんたちの出家者のことを言って
アナーガタッパジャッパヤ
アナーガタっていうのはまだ起きてない将来のこと
ジャッパティっていうのはごちゃごちゃ考えること
将来のことをまあまああれやこれやとか悩んだり考えて生きていますね
みんな それから まあ将来のことを悶々と考えている
アティータッス 終わったことについて
アヌソーチャナ 悩んじゃうんですよ
大体過去の場合はそういう癖なんですよ
過去が失敗したことがいつでも忘れられなくなっちゃうんですね
成功したことはそんなにあまり問題になりませんだけど
だから終わったことについて
いつでもアヌソーチャナ悩んでるんですね
まだ起きてないことには心配して心配して
将来について 過去についてはもう悩んだり悩んだりして
そんなことでエーテーナ
そういうことで バーラー
これお釈迦様よく使う言葉
愚か者という いわゆる一般の人々のことなんです
バーラーというのは無知な人
人々 無知な人々はスッサンティ
枯れていくんだよ スッサンティというのは
どんどんどんどん枯れて枯れて
枯れるというか 痩せて痩せて
もう力何もない ドライヤー
英語で言えばドライヤー
ドライですか 枯れ 何ですかね
ドライヤー  干からび  え？ 干からび
干からび うん ドライヤー
干からびること 例えばあります
ナローワハリトーロト
ナラ これはエ入ってますが
えーと これがこちらになるんだ
まあいいです ナレっていうのは竹のことです
竹のように春と今緑ですが
ると切ってしまえば緑色の竹が生きている竹なんですけど
一旦切ってしまえばどうなるかというと
どんどん あの元気な色も全部なくなってしまう
だから竹がもうそのまんまだったら
どんどんどんどん成長するでしょうに
これ切っちゃえばどうなるかというと
ですから 我々一般人の生き方というのは
まあ切ってしまった竹のようなもんだよと
持っているエネルギーもどんどんどんどん消えちゃって
枯れてすっかりてしまいますよ
これは何なのかというと
過去のことを悩む 将来のことは心配するというくだらない妄想のせいだ
それから省略してほんのちょっとだけ紹介します
で 人間 自分を改良したいと良くなりたいと思うならば
一番一番というか まあ一番ですね
お釈迦様の言葉から言えば
便利な簡単便利なインスタントの方法があります
みんなインスタントの法則ですからね
これが 一応これは一応覚えておいてください
この偈をね 最後にこの切った竹のように妄想するとすっかりてしまいますよと
だから人間というのは年より老けているはもう体
もう本当に体もそうなってしまいますよ
次それからたくさんありますけど
一言葉だけ書いておきます
書いて残りは早口で言います
これ今長いんですけど
その言葉だけ送ってもよろしいと思います
覚えなくてもいいんですね
意味だけでもね サッビレーヴァ サマーセータ
これがインスタントの方法なんですよ
サッビっていうのは良い人
善人 立派な人 できている人
その人とだけサッビレーヴァ
共存するんですよ サマーセーと付き合いなさいよ
仲良くしなさいよ 優れている人格的に優れている
立派な善人 善友 自分よりとてもできている人と仲良くしなさいよと
どんな方法でもいいんで
その人の召使いになったっても構いません
それがインスタント方法ですよ
成長するために みんな努力をあまりしたくないでしょ
お釈迦様は努力しなさいと言っていますけどね
努力しなくしたくない怠け者であろうとも
それなりの人格者に尽くすと
もうあっという間に良くなります
良くならないで済むわけじゃないんです
それぐらい人間っていうのはもう簡単に調整できます
この付き合う付き合って付き合うっていうのは
あの男女の付き合いではなくて
人との付き合い まあ仲良くすることで
それによってものすごく影響を受けるんですよ
皆さんはそうでしょう
自分の人格は何もないんだから
周りを見て自分が調整するんだから
だから無茶苦茶でしょうね
言ってることとやってることは違うわ
もう時々何言ってるかもわからないし
何やってるかもわからないし
なんでこの色の服買って買いましたかというとわからない
自分でも みんな買ってるんだからと
そんなもんで もう情けない生き方でしょ
大体人間というのはね
やっぱり周りの環境は受けますからね
ですから仏教ではこのインスタント法としてサッビレーヴァ サマーセーと付き合うならば
できてる善人 人格者と付き合ってみなさいと
それから延々とこの言葉が続けて
そういうことをすると
サタンサッダンママンニャエ
その人はこの真理は何なのかと
いわゆる本当の生き方何なのかと自分で自動的に知ってしまいますよ
できた人と付き合うと
人格者と付き合うと それでセイヨーホーティナパーピヨ
良い人と付き合うとどんどん正用法で良くなりますよと
決して悪くなることはありませんと
次のところでパンニャーラッベティナーンヤと
そうやって善人と付き合うと
今まで自分になかった知恵がどんどんどんどん自分に入ってくるんだと
それから このことを実行するとソーカマッジェノソーチェティ
悩んでいる人々の間で自分が何も悩むことなくいられますよと
悩みに溺れている世界ですよ
悩み苦しみに それで良い人と付き合うならば
その人は自分が悩むことなくいられますよと
もう一つ 二つの偈があって
そんなことをするならばニャーティマッジェビローチェティ親戚の中で輝くぞと
ということは やはり自分の仲間の中で自分が飛び出して輝いているんですね
成功しているんですよ
それにはサッビレーワサマセ
それは条件で良い人と付き合ってください
それから良い人と付き合うならばサッターガッチャンティスッガティ
その人が天界に行くんだと
いわゆるスッガティっていうのは
いいところへ いい方向へ行きますよという意味なんですね
死んでも大丈夫です 死んでも天国に行きます
もし良い人と付き合うならばサッターティッタンティサーカタン
良い人と付き合うと いつでも平安な穏やかな心でいられますよ
そういう風な このお釈迦様の言葉なんですけど
ある人々が自分たち覚えている偈をお釈迦様の前に言ったんです
私はこれを覚えて実践しているんだと
それでお釈迦様に聞くんです
どちらの言葉がよろしいですか？って言ったら
お釈迦様は君たちみんなまあなかなかいい言葉言ってるんだよと
しかし 私も一つ付け加えますよと
言って お釈迦様は同じ偈で言うんですね
良い人と付き合いなさい
その場合はサタンサッダママンニャエ
本当の真理を知ってサッバドゥッカパムッチャティ
一切の苦しみから脱しますよと
いわゆる涅槃 解脱も体験できるぞと
わかりますかね 人生の成功から最終的な解脱するところまで
たった一つの出来事でできるんです
良い人と付き合ってみなさいよ
人格者に それも一つの自分を改革するとき
やってもよろしいことですね
で 最後に一つまたあるんですが
あるだけで全部言ったって意味がないんだから
一つだけ選んでおわりにします
これある神の女子か女性の神の話なんです
名前としてはインド文化では大変有名な美しい神なんですよ
その女性 神と言っても
ただのどれかのすごい美しい女の人と思ったっても構いませんしね
だいたい女性の中でもいますね
すごく頭のいい 頭のいい女の人っていうのはごちゃごちゃ考えないんです
すごい気楽にいるんですよ
であんまり考えちゃうと
もう男でも女でもね もうダメになっちゃいますからね
この女性 この神がお釈迦様のところに来てこう言うんです
まず自分が来たことをちゃんと報告して
こういうこういう名前のこういうこういう私が来ましたよと
バフーナアピコウタンビバジェイアンパリヤーエナターディソウダンモン
あなたはあらゆる方法でたくさん説法していますよと
その人にその人に合わせて
その場でその場でいろんな分析しながら
まあ嫌なほどたくさん説法してるんだよと
サンキッタマッタンラパギッサマヤーワターメーマナサパリヤッタン
でも私がね 釈尊があらゆることを説法していることはね
全部考えてね 自分なりに全部まとめましたと
単純に この女性は単純に考える人なんですね
私はそんなたくさん まあそれは私が入れますけどね
そんなたくさん覚えるのめんどくさいし
わからないことは論理やら理屈さいっぱいあるし
とにかく私は自分なりに自分に理解できるようにまとめましたよと
それを聞いてくださいと
それでまとめて言うんですよ
パーパンナカイラ 悪いことをするなかれ
マナワジャサマナサカーエナ
頭でも悪いことをしてはいけません
悪い考え方をやめなさいと
悪い思考をやめなさいと
ワジャサ 喋ってはいけませんと悪いことは
カーエナ 体でも悪いことをするのはやめましょうと
キンジャナサッバローケ
この人間の生命の中で生きている場合は
全くも絶対悪いことを考えてはいけないし
悪いことを言ってはいけないし
悪いことはやってはいけないと
それからカーメーパハヤ
欲は捨てましょうと あまり欲張るといいことになりませんと
欲は捨てましょう サティマサンパジャノ
日々 その瞬間瞬間のことに気づいていましょう
それからドゥッカンナセーウェータアナッタサンギタン
自分に不幸になる苦しみを追いかけるなと
全部お釈迦様の教えをまとめちゃったんです
だから彼女にとってはその偈でそれを覚えて仏教を実践していた神ですからね
やっぱりそこでかなりまとめてもっとわかりやすい偈もたくさんありますが
えっとまあ こちらで彼女が言っているのは
この生きている間は悪いこと
余計なこと 無意味なことを考えない
無意味なことを喋らない
無意味なことはしません
絶対しません それからあまり欲張ってはいけませんと
あまりではなくて 欲張ってはいけません
欲張ると全部なくなります
この能力なんかなくなるのはそういうわけなんですよ
例えばノーベル賞を取ったあの方にしたっても
若い人の場合でもね やっぱり別に欲張ってないんですね
ただまあ何か遊びでやったことでノーベル賞までもらったらノーベル賞もらう
夢でも考えたことはない
何か得るそうと思ったら
体も心も固くなるんですよ
だから失敗する だから人間の失敗の元一つ欲
それから怒りも同じで
怒りと欲と無知っていうのは全てパーになっちゃう
しかし 我々は怒りと欲で生きているんですよ
良くなりたい 良くなりたいと欲のことを考えちゃう
なりません 逆になっちゃう
怒りで勝ちたい 勝ちたいと思っちゃうと負ける
だから彼女は言っているのは
やっぱり欲っていうことはかなりヘンディになりますから
これは抑えましょうと
それから妄想をやめますから
瞬間瞬間のことだけ考えてみましょうと
それから苦しみを負うんじゃないんだよと
苦しみから脱すること考えましょうと
それがブッダの教えでしょうっていうことをお釈迦様は何も言ってないんです
それには 彼女は勝手に言って帰っちゃったんです
では帰りますと 私にとってはある程度で
なんとなくまあ気持ちはわかるんです
やっぱりあんまり理屈ばっかりダラダラと並んで喋ると
女性っていうのは嫌がるっていうことはありますよ
わかりやすく単純短絡で言いなさいよと
だからかのじがそうやって自分でまとめたんです
それからみんなまああの
あれこれやると物を持ちたくなる
家を持ちたくなる 金をたくさん持ちたくなる
家族を持ちたくくなる
えらい危険です そんなの
自分を良くなると成功すると思って持つこと考えてるんですよ
で 持つこと全部置いていくんですよ
財産も置いて死ぬんですよ
置いて置いておいて死ぬんですよ
一つも自分のものじゃないんですよ
家族がいても 家族がいたままで自分が死んじゃいますね
だからバカなことですよ
これが私の これが私の
これがと言ったって 死ぬ時は全部置いておいて持っていく
だからそうやって頑張ることは無駄
無意味だと だから死ぬまで何を収穫するか
何を獲得するかと 何を儲かるべきかというと
持っていくもの 自分のもの
それが性格ですよ だから良い性格を作る
清らかな性格を作る それが持っていけます
死ぬ時 はい 性格も置いておきますと
できません ということで
あの プンニャン 功徳を持っていきますと
功徳っていうのは善行為の結果なんですね
良いことをしてすればそれだけは持っていけます
ですから せっかく儲かる儲かると頑張るんだから
ここで誰か置いておくものを持っていった
儲かったっても意味がないんです
だから持っていくものは一生懸命持っていかれるものは
儲かるようにしましょうと
それは仏教では功徳というんですね
パーリ語ではプンニャと言うんですね
プンニャ 善行為ですね
自分が行った善行為だけは自分と一緒
はい まあ時間はもう時間と言えるところじゃないですか
ないので はい そこら辺で終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます
だいぶ時間をですね 過ぎておりますが
何かどなたか質問等ございましたらしてください
はい ではおはようございます
質問等よろしいでしょうか
ではもう質問がないようなので
最後に長老のお話を聞いて
ではエコノーマ  ご当山の三宝に帰依し
戒の法に非非の瞑想と仏道の実践によって積まれた功徳と
神々 先祖 祖先を供養し
氏族 恩師をはじめとし
一切の生きとし生けるものに廻向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして苦悩から免れますように
サンビティヨ イマンジャント サッバローゴ ウィナッサト マーテー バワットワンタラーヨ スキーディーガーユコー
バヴァ バワトゥ サッバマンガラン ラッカントゥ サッバデーヴァター サッバブンダアヌバーヴェーナ サッバダンマアヌ
バーヴェーナ サッバサンガーアヌバーヴェーナ サダーソッティバワントゥ テ アビワダナシーリスー ニッチャンワッダーパジャヤーイノ
チャッターロ ダンマーワンタンティー アユアンノー スカンバラン
では 長い時間本当に時間延ばしちゃって申し訳ございません
どうもありがとうございました
[効果音]